these are the latest creations from
French designer Leia pika the 30 year
old is one of the up and coming artists
featured at this week's Paris Fashion
Week she learned her trade with Jean
Paul Gautier and he's a bed mahon but
she decided to break out on her own this
misery don't brilliance I wanted to
stand on my own two feet quickly maybe I
could have worked longer for a fashion
label but I was too impatient to be
independent this is the second time that
leah has been on the official calendar
of the puente potatios in paris the
city's fashion Chamber of Commerce has
specific criteria for participants no
she s DS don't think ooh yay we look for
people who are different from others
whose fashion can be exported that means
it has to be creative enough to interest
foreign purchasing agents and the
Foreign Press what's interesting is that
in our little milieu buyers journalists
and fashion experts eventually reach
consensus about who was a new talent and
that's the case with leah claro de novo
know the party chura liya went into
business for herself three years ago and
has developed a style all her own a
mixture of feminine and masculine
components with a lot of attention to
detail still most with you miss Trina I
like it masculine and I like it
comfortable and I'm increasingly
developing this side on the other hand
are like a certain feminine touch a
woman wearing high heels I dream of
being a woman like that too and in my
collection dream and in reality mix
citrusy to see a part in the dog ever el
Apache doing anything of it so stinky
did eV first I'll derives from men's
fashions you can see your challenge
through the way she designs and cuts or
suits she makes men's fashion soft and
feminine and creates a new form of
womanliness it's not sex in your vulgar
we need a new term for it
you know she reminds me of Jack a moose
who is also very young and like her
brings a breath of fresh air to the
fashion see caffeine would extend more
finished the 25 year old Jackie moose is
another name to follow his show is a
must see even if it's being held in a
rundown old building but that doesn't
scare the fashions elite or its top
critics Lucas is Jack a moose is someone
people are talking about more and more
of his creations are showing up in
fashion magazines he's got his very own
personal style that's causing quite a
stir Jacques amuses background is far
from the Paris fashion scene he grew up
in the country and studied fashion in
Paris but quit after only a month jhumpa
saga' I'm the son of a farmer who had no
contact with the fashion scene and now
i'm creating fashion yes to acknowledge
maybe that's why I have such a rough
approach the boy tell you to his models
come out barefoot and is unstructured in
symmetrical dresses there are lots of
skin shaggy moose makes fashion his way
ignoring all the familiar conventions
chithi obsidia power this time I was
influenced by childhood yes I imagined a
little boy or girl just having fun
picking out all kinds of things and
sewing clothes out of them and putting
on masks and makeup this freedom and
naivete that kids have fascinates me his
unconventional approach may well be the
key to his success recently for the
second time the young designer was
nominated for the louisvuitton fashion
award hey pop was bitching at least
while he shows us creations that aren't
really classical and the way we'd expect
them to be is changing our perspective
on fashion these creative young talents
are the designers of tomorrow who are
making a fashion of tomorrow they have
the French know how along with a new
energy in a certain dose of optimism
that sentiment seems to be reflected by
the audience at Leia peg
the industry insiders are also excited
about he won a national here we're lucky
to have access to the big companies and
famous labels but that's not enough
don't keeping an eye on the
up-and-coming talent is part of our job
riete Beckler numbers among the
outstanding new designers and we're
counting on her for now the young
designers are presenting their creations
under their own names but it might just
be a matter of time before they're
scooped up by the big fashion houses